want to say hello to our audience today
my name is Stuart Creek I'm with
simply learned and we'll be getting
started in just a moment with Vinita
rastoki of PayPal
um give me just one moment to get our
LinkedIn stream started
or our streaming audience
you would think that would be a one
button operation but it actually
takes a little more effort than that
all right
and Welcome to our streaming audience on
LinkedIn live as well as YouTube
and of course here live on WebEx
let's get started
as I mentioned my name is Stuart Creek
I'm a marketing manager here at simply
learn and with us today is Victor
rastogi who is a senior manager of data
science at PayPal and this interview
prep master class is how to crack a data
science interview at a top Silicon
Valley company
for those of you in data science who are
looking to get into the top tier of
technology companies be a great session
for you if you're on the WebEx
session please enter your questions for
Vinita in the Q a panel
we'll also keep an eye on the chat but
most of the questions we'll take from
the Q a panel and if you're on our
streaming service please put your
questions in the comments somebody
should be able to pass those on to us
um we'll also ask a couple of questions
just the first one today is very simple
two parts one is how much experience you
have in the workplace not necessarily in
data science but in the workplace
and number two
how are you feeling today
yes that's second question because of uh
the effects of our last couple of years
of the pandemic
give you about another 10 seconds to
answer
foreign
[Music]
here is the result of this poll question
and you can see that we have a very even
distribution unit of uh experience in
the audience
at all different levels
and unfortunately nearly everybody is
doing well or doing okay
we're glad to hear that as well
absolutely
just a little bit about you and you can
talk more about yourself I'm sure
introduce yourself better than I can
as I mentioned you're the senior data
science manager PayPal uh can you talk a
little bit more about your background
before we get started
um absolutely so I have nine years of
experience in a field of data science I
started my career as a data analyst you
know in Bangalore with a company called
Brady Corporation and there from there I
moved to genpact
and uh after that you know I took a
career break I think this is some of the
things that you would like to hear more
about and then I shifted to UK and I
started working as a senior data science
scientist you know all the way through
that I actually keep on upskilling
myself
for that and you know during the
pandemic it was stuff I think on
everyone uh we thought about our family
and we moved back to India
and uh yeah I started working with
people I think recently
two months back the people are working
uh in a GCSE Group which is Global
Credit seller and Collections and I lead
a team over there who looks into the
consumer and Merchant payments because
the inside draw the analysis and we
share these insights with the you know
different teams called strategy or
oblations who can actually use these
insights to build or you know maybe
change the strategy as per the business
so our role is quite crucial
okay
um
it's interesting uh just as a lead-off
question
how is that how have you seen fintech
change in the last
several years
you know PayPal started a number of
years ago I don't think the word fintech
was nearly as widely used as it is now
but
um now with the Advent of the micro
Banks and microcredit and that type of
thing
um how has that affected
that market and
how has data science especially
played into that
I think data science is kind of a
buzzword now we were doing you know
mostly the similar things back then as
well PayPal was established in around
1998 somewhere in November December
right they started you know one of the
company I think that people were the
first company where you know who comes
with a digital payments option and uh if
you see the uh trajectory right in the
last couple of years it has emerged like
like a leader right not just the PayPal
but you have seen multi you know there
are many companies who have uh opened
and maybe it's GPA or paytm or the other
companies right who have actually opened
and come into the fintech environment
as this covet times uh you can say the
pandemic times have grown the uh uh um
you say the growth you can see the
growth actually in each you know during
this time especially and if we talk
about the data science we used to do the
analysis back then as well we call it as
you know analysis and research and you
know the statistical analysis but now
the quality you know data science the
data science is nothing but it's a
combination of your programming skill
It's a combination of your statistical
skills
um uh you do your research you do your
analysis you draw the insights initially
you know earlier we used to draw the
graphs on Excel now we do it on the
power bi or Tableau right so I think we
used to do the similar things back then
as well but now we have much more in
terms of Technology why why because the
data has increased immensely in the last
couple of years right we have so huge
data that now the data can't fit in in
any hard drive or in any system rights
and that's why we have the clouds now to
manage the data and to analyze that data
you needs new uh new tools and
Technologies and that's why we started
using some of the tools
some of the languages like python are vo
SQL you know day in day out to analyze
the data we use the uh dashboards we use
the uh data visualization tools you know
in our company Tableau click
microstrategy you know to analyze or to
to visualize the data right so I don't
say that you know it has changed
drastically but I think the methods has
changed the The Core Concepts have
remained the same we have changed the
terminologies but we are still doing you
know similar things which we were doing
you know back then as well
okay
um and so the explosion of data I assume
that that means that there's been a a
huge growth and demand for people to
manage the data in analysts data
scientists
um data Engineers
um and so where where does PayPal
um or you know its peers in Silicon
Valley where do you go to find
Talent you need data science
sorry can you come again with that sure
where are the places that you look for
new hires uh to bring on board in data
science where do you recruit from
so one of the medium is our job boards
right so our HR work tremendously you
know they work very hard to filter the
resume so please if you are interested
in any of the opportunity in PayPal
please do see the profiles and the roles
in the PayPal website and apply you know
through that because I did the same
really trust me on that the second thing
where actually I go to see you know
people for my team is either I get the
references from HR or I look into the
LinkedIn I don't go to naukri I don't go
to any website to be honest
and um
when somebody comes to a job borders
going through some type of website is is
it really a matter of that first
screening happens by Machine Do you have
like AI tools that look at resumes and
TVs and filter out
you know the candidates that that move
on to talk to people
um you can see it's kind of it's there I
won't say you know it's not there but
it's again depends on HR as well so you
know sometimes for some dis some
positions when you have a lot of
applications right you do have to use
machine for that but for some you know
for some roles we actually do read the
resume so I I usually get like 20 to 30
resumes uh if at all I have to you know
hire somebody so I do go through the
resumes as well
and and what what are the some of the
things that stand out when you look at
those resumes what are the some of the
things that um catch your attention and
either make somebody look like a good
candidate or things that you see as red
flags
for me the most important thing is you
know the kind of experience so I'm
talking here about you know people who
have experience so uh we'll talk about
the pressures later so yeah I mean I
usually have the experienced candidates
to be honest so I usually look for the
experience the kind of experience you
know the kind of projects that they have
done so I actually read through the
resume and actually you know read
through the project that they have done
and I try to understand you know what is
the business problem that they are
trying to solve during you know with
these projects yes so I think that is
really important for me because end of
the day it's it's not about your machine
learning techniques it's not about the
kind of model that you have built
because that can be done you know by
anyone who have you know taken training
from somewhere but the problem solving
skills is is really important for me the
business domain knowledge is important
for me so I look for those things and of
course the technical skills you know how
good the person how how good they sound
you know technically
and and on the other side as I mentioned
are there are there things that stand
out in a resume to you that say this is
probably not a good candidate
um
people actually talk a lot about you
know um
I would say they sometimes they take
about the projects they think that you
know we don't know but we kind of know
uh the kind of things that they write
right because
what they are doing is it's something
that you know we have seen it from last
so many years right so the kind of
projects the kind of language they put
on the resume
it clearly makes so that you know that
it it's not real it's not something that
they have done
okay so you can always tell when
somebody is is padding their resume or
or
the time yes absolutely
can you uh when and want to talk about
the freshers now we can but if uh if you
prefer to talk about the process we've
started the process of somebody's resume
has come in you've reviewed it uh you've
made a short list of the people that you
want to talk to who will they talk to
will they start with you or are there
other people that they begin with and
then they get an HR screening first and
then move to you or what's the progress
of that progression yeah it completely
depends on the kind of role we are
hiring for so if at all we are hiring
for the data scientist or data
engineering role right so the first step
is the online test right the HR will
contact the person and give the online
test so the person has to give the
online test you know it will be consist
of programming uh the statistical uh
knowledge and problem solving right so
those are the three competencies we look
for and once this feeling is done
then uh there are a couple of people uh
that who takes the interview so there
are two phase of the interviews
basically so one is with the manager so
it can be with me or with you know one
of my colleagues and the other one is
the technical again it could be with me
or with my colleague it's completely
depend on the availability right
so there are two interviews with the
manager so the first interview in the
first interview what we look for is the
oh you know we just want to understand
you know the the person so we would like
to know them you know uh on a personal
level you know what kind of work they
have done you know how they have
approached the problem why they have
done you know if they have done
something why they have done is done it
right so we go through the resume talk
about pick up a project we talk about it
right so we try to understand you know
what kind of problem they are solving
why they are solving who is their target
audience what is the success Matrix for
the project those kind of things so
which is I would say semi-technical but
not completely technical uh once the
person cleared this interview the next
step is with the you know the with the
technical manager so the technical
interview is more about you know your
programming skill your statistical
skills and uh obviously with the
questions like guest estimates or uh
uh maybe given a scenario and you know
they have to approach so here also you
know we would like to see how the person
is trying to approach the problem
I think that is the key thing I think
most people miss this because they focus
too much on their programming skills
that they forget about how to actually
approach a business problem right
yeah most of the time that we have
observed I mean I'll tell you the
personal experience here that when we
actually give them the problem you know
they start with the data they completely
you know they just start with the data
with the you know some some kind of
analysis okay some kind of correlations
and then getting into the future
engineering creating new variables this
and that and then finally you know with
the model but nobody actually come back
and ask you know what are the problem
that we are trying to solve here who is
going to be our target audience why you
think it's a business problem right and
you know what would be your success
Matrix I think those are the questions
that they should be asking rather than
you know just jumping on the data
so yeah there are few things that I
think are important from our perspective
and you know
um yeah
so that's the second step yeah that's
the third step I would say the last step
is actually the um
which actually distinguish the top tier
companies with the uh small or medium
companies is
the behavioral and cultural fit and guys
when I'm saying this trust me on it that
we actually look for a candidate who who
has a cultural fit for the company it is
as important as having you know a
technical skill
right we would like to know you you know
how you are as a person
how you actually try to solve problem
for your team how you you know behave or
you interact with your teammates
uh you know how you approach different
people you know so these are some of the
things that we actually look for
um so
after the HR screening and the in the
initial online test
the managerial interview get a general
feel for the person the technical
interview to dig deep into their skills
and then assessing that cultural bit to
see how they'll fit on the team right
yeah
um
so what
are the differences in the process for
freshers who don't have the
background of experience to bring
so the process is still remain the same
right the process is is completely same
that's the actually beauty of the top
tier company right because they are very
very organized so if we are hiring for a
role of a data scientist if it's for a
pressure right with zero to two years of
experience say the process will still
remain the same there will be a coding
test there will be a managerial round
there will be a technical ground as well
of course you won't be having any you
know uh experienced uh experience or you
know you are working projects that you
have done for a say uh for a company but
you do have a portfolio right because
when you practice data science you do
practice some problems right you go to
kaggle you you know you try to solve
some you maybe participate in some
competitions how you approach that
problem those kind of things so we do
look for portfolio if you have any and
what are the kind of you know
probably problems that you have solved
or you have shown on your resume so we
do look for that
and
when you're
you're pressure building a portfolio
you put more emphasis on
classroom projects that people have done
where they can demonstrate yes I did
this in a course but I this is the the
result of the project I can show you or
do you um
put equal or more emphasis on things
like open source
competitions or or projects that they've
aged in
um
it's equal so we it's not like if they
have done you know classroom projects
they get you know less marks and if they
have done some open source project they
get more money so nothing like that the
the you know
the criteria is based on your
understanding what do you understand
when you were trying to solve that you
know problem what do you understand what
what's uh you know learning for you out
of that project what did you learn from
it right what kind of analysis what what
kind of you know exploratory analysis
that you have done what are the feature
engineering if any what was the you know
uh relationship what kind of models that
you have built and why did you choose
you know you know probably one model
over the other one and why the questions
are you know more or less the same for
both the cases we do give equal uh marks
for you know both both the things yeah
okay now is most of the interviewing
still in this in this environment is
most of the interviewing being done
over
um you know
online tools like
zoom and and
Skype and that type of thing yes
absolutely it's completely virtual as of
now yeah
okay
um does that give you the opportunity
then for somebody who's doing the
interview to to share their screen from
their system and show you some of their
work
that part of the interview process we
usually don't ask for it but if they
have something to show and if they
request I mean we are open for it
okay so what are some of the the
questions that you're going to ask in
the technical well
you you mentioned but I'm not sure if I
understood correctly if you're if you
were
your interviews are more on the
technical assessment side or more on the
managerial side which is good it's good
as I said it's completely depend on the
availability right
okay so what what are some of the things
that in that managerial interview what
are some of the questions that that
people can expect to be asked should be
ready to to
deal with
um so when we uh so there are you know
two levels of questions so when we ask
you know the pressures we ask more about
the hypothesis testing we mostly ask
about the performance made rights about
you know uh the model for the models
they have used right what kind of
performance Matrix they have used and
why you know which one they feel is
better one and why those kind of
questions what is the p-value why we use
p-value you know what is the importance
of it
okay some of those questions these are
for the pressures
for the experienced one we
we go a little bit deeper you know how
how have you done the sampling what is
the you know problem statement uh
what was your approach initially how you
did the data Gathering uh if you have
you know so many variables you know how
do you actually shrink it to you you
know uh what was your selection criteria
those kind of things because they have
more experience into the industry right
so obviously they have worked on the
real data sets
and
that brings up an interesting question
as well of how
does a person get familiarity with the
domain
um say somebody hasn't worked in the
financial fintech industry but what what
can they do to show that they're
interested informed and ready to work in
that sector when they talk to you
Stuart it might comes as a surprise to
you but I was not from the finance
background when I started working with
great and UK so I worked with genpact I
was working with the aviation industry
and the data was you know completely
different right so for me and even you
know I mean that kind of interview that
I gave over there and the kind of
interview that I take here
it not necessarily depends on you know
the company or the industry that you
have worked for
or if you do have the domain knowledge
if you have a business knowledge it's
good it's like icing on the cake right
but even if you don't have it's not
compulsory
that's very interesting that uh actually
I think a lot of people in the audience
might find that reassuring that they
that they can
talk to somebody in a particular company
and not feel like
they're a huge disadvantage if they've
never worked in that industry before
you think you know it's fit for you
if you don't hear back that's completely
fine right but what if you know you get
a response
um so we we use the word data scientist
a lot but did it data scientists
sometimes gives the the image of
somebody who's very experienced and
thinking at a very high level and maybe
even almost a theoretical level about
some of these problems what is what is
the kind of career path for somebody
who's coming into this field uh as a
fresher what what jobs would they
realistically apply for
so I would suggest so there are
completely depends on the job
descriptions because if you
let's be honest if you see the job
descriptions in in today's environment
they want to have everything under our
data science you know tag right be it
data engineering profile or be it you
know data analyst they want to have
everything you know person should know
everything but that's not true right
that's not true
if you are a fresher and if you would
like to get into the data science
profile I would suggest to start you
know looking into the data and this job
because I think the first step towards
the data size or the hyped data science
word is is more about you know how you
actually start looking at the data right
how you understand it so it's more about
you know analyzing it you know how you
actually try to find the insights and
then convert into some recommendations
right
so that is more important
so if you are a fresher and if you would
like to get into the data science domain
you can try for the data analyst profile
because
for the data scientist job there are
very less vacancies who actually look
for the pleasure
right so yeah start looking for the data
analyst or uh
yeah that that's all I can think of or
maybe you know in some companies even
under the tag business analyst they
actually give the same description about
the profile so yeah
do you find
um this is a question about the working
environment do you find that
um people who are working on
at the analyst level
um do they have a lot of interaction
with people at higher levels of the
company to get visibility or if that
filtered through their their chain of
command
uh no so I mean that's the beauty here
so
there are you know different level of
data scientists who reports to me and
then I report to the director and that
he reports to the VP and then he reposed
to the you know uh the uh SVP right but
if I want I can actually get in touch
with the VP directly without you know
having my manager into the uh into the
conversation
and same way my manager you know they
interact with my reportees directly
so it's not like so it's a completely
open culture where you can actually go
and speak to anybody of any level
of course I mean
it's not like you're gonna go to the EVP
and you know start chatting with them
but then if you want to work if you want
to ask something if you need some help
with someone if you need some kind of
request from someone you can approach
anybody
that's I mean that's that's I think a
good thing about the data science field
that you're dealing with business
information and people need to get the
answers so they don't necessarily want
to
um wait for this process to filter
through the official chain
um and and that means the people who are
just starting out get a chance to talk
to people above them maybe a couple of
levels you get a chance to be to be seen
and to move up the organization get
opportunities to ask for stuff about the
visibility as well right so the
pressures or you know the people who
just join maybe with like two or three
years experience right
they actually get charged to speak with
the leaders right but directly if they
are working on some important project
right the leader will actually you know
send you a message on teams you know
what's the status how it's going you
know can we have a quick call so you can
you don't have to wait for me or my
manager or his manager right to have to
get that information they can actually
connect with each other regardless of
their designation or their roles right
that that's always a a great thing
um now in
getting back to the the the interviewing
process so
um how deep will the technical interview
go in terms of uh
do you what's what's the kind of
technique that you used and you take a
problem and say let's solve this
together and show me how you do it or do
you ask a series of questions
I usually don't do you know things where
actually I ask them to you know ask them
to put in front of me I don't do that
because that thing is already over in
that first round you know so they're I
know they are good at coding that's why
they cleared that long run so I don't
need to see that but what I do is I
always throw a problem
to them that you know and ask them you
know how would you solve it and I
actually want to see the approach for me
it doesn't matter you know what is the
answer they're coming out with I
actually
like to know you know how they are
approaching the problem what is their
technique what is their methodology you
know what are the certain steps and
actually that you know that complete
method you know it tells me that how
they have you know what kind of
experience they have
foreign
do you
when you're walking through that how how
um how far into the problem solution do
you go I mean how much time will will
you spend on
an interview segment like that uh I
don't segment right so uh it's
completely depend on the candidate
they actually go deeper and deeper into
the modeling into the model into the you
know Matrix we'll go to that
we just want to see you know how they
are doing it you know how they are
approaching it it's completely on them
how they want to take the direction of
the interview
so we always you know think that you
know it's not the interviewer it's you
guys who can take the interview in a
certain direction in your direction
so wherever your strength lies in
right yeah
I was going to say that that then brings
up the question what are the the
uh kinds of directions that people can
take you in an interview that get you
interested in them as a potential
employee
um and what are some of the you know
directions that would take you
you know in a different direction and
say you know they're not focused on the
on the on the answer here
see it's very easy to answer this
question because most of the times they
actually go in the direction and they go
deeper and deeper into that that you
know at some point of time they actually
lost you know where they were coming
from
so they kind of lost you know why we did
this because you ask questions right I
asked why you are doing this and this is
what this you know you could have
approached it in this when they're like
uh yeah and they they're kind of not
they're kind of lost over there so you
know right you can relate it yeah I mean
now that's the end
and how do you know if they are
successful because those who knows uh
what are their strengths they actually
take the interview where their strength
lies so if they're good at you know
statistical
skills right they will take the
interview probably into the uh you know
the technicalities the mathematical
aspects of the uh the model and the
excel in it because they know in and out
of it
right so I mean you can differentiate
it's very easy you do it once and you'll
find it out
the you just reminded me of something
from a long time ago there is a
a stage play that was popular many years
ago about the um
the cartoon the comic strip peanuts with
Carly Brown and Snoopy and that type of
thing and in this uh
stage play it's a musical uh there's a a
song number where all of the children
are being asked to write a book report
about the book Peter Rabbit
and the one thing that stood out for me
in this conversation is one of the
children has never read the book Peter
Rabbit but he's read the book Robin Hood
that's his favorite book so he writes
his book report Peter Rabbit kind of
reminds me of Robin Hood and then he
goes completely into that direction so
when you talk about people taking it in
Direction I understand what you mean
when people will take it in a direction
that they're most comfortable with or
the thing that they feel that their
strongest with exactly
and um so do you recommend that people
do a self-assessment of that and say you
know I'm very strong in this area
here are other areas where I should be
stronger in case I need to ask you know
answer that or work on that part of I
think that we should hold it you know at
some point of time because after every
interview you know after every rejection
I think we all do that at some point of
time right and this self-assessment is
something that we should do it on a
regular basis because it helps you to
know that you know what are your
improvement areas and where you need to
work more on right so if you are good in
the programming if you are good in
statistical skills probably you might
need to work more on the storytelling
skills maybe you might need to work more
on the you know how to approach the
problem maybe you might need to work
more on you know uh see how data
visualization what are the kind of
analysis that you can you know show to
come up with a Insight maybe you know so
I think we we all should yeah I I think
they should do it yeah
okay
um
when somebody is very strong in one area
um not as strong in other areas you
sometimes hire them for that strength
and say that you can you know bring them
along in the other areas or are you
looking for somebody who's going to be
you know if they're strong in one area
they're at least
pretty strong in the other areas as well
it completely depends on the area
so it's not like so if it all uh you
know they are good at programming they
are good at statistical skills but you
know they lack some bit of save
you know problem solving or the
storytelling skills
you know it's kind of okay because they
learn with time
the more they interact with the
stakeholders the more they present their
you know presentations in the uh
leadership meeting they will learn it
eventually right maybe they might not
have got this opportunity earlier and if
you talk about the freshers they don't
get this opportunity a part of you know
a part of presenting something maybe in
the class I don't think they get you
know this opportunity right so that is
something I think they can learn on the
job
but if they don't know about you know
they don't they lack statistical skills
they don't know you know uh what is the
basics of the you know the the stats I
think then there's a problem
yeah okay so there are certain core
skills that are that does a priority
yeah okay that makes sense
um
so
if you're giving advice to the people in
the audience about how to prepare
or this interview process
um what can they do beforehand
before they come in to the to the zoom
meeting with you
um what should they have ready at their
fingertips or what what kinds of
preparation can they do
okay so I'm not going to tell you you
know what kind of uh uh you know
programming that you should Ace in or
what kind of question I will be asking
you in this uh from the studs I'm giving
you a general idea about how you should
approach not just this but any interview
right
please do read about the role that you
are applying for right do read about you
know try to understand the position that
you are applying for and try to
customize your resume based on your you
know your research if you would like
your resume to be filtered I think
that's that's a you know that's the main
thing because
there are times when you actually send
the same resume to 100 different
positions and you think that why you are
not getting the response clearly you
have not seen the job description you
have not read about the role what are
they asking for and that's the reason
your resume is not getting filtered
right so do read about the rule
second thing is please do read about the
company as well to the company you are
applying for shouldn't be like you know
I'm telling you you know what people is
doing I I you know I really hope that
you know at least you know something
about PayPal
I know you don't know you know the
insights of what exactly we do work wise
but I do understand if you Google you
know just about paper you'll get tons of
information which will actually tell you
you know what is the business model and
how the PayPal works right so at least
that level of information I expect from
the candidate
the other thing is when you actually you
know come for the interview please do
practice some interview responses
especially your introduction because
that's a very crucial one that gives the
first impression on the interviewer
normally you you know you come and you
just say your name and you know you
where you have you know fall get your
education from or probably what kind of
degree you have I think you need to
elaborate more about you know if you
have experienced more about experience
and achievements and be thorough with it
be confident about you know about your
introduction do not fumble do not
stammer over there because if you are
not confident about your stuff how can
you expect the you know interviewer to
be confident get that confidence for you
right so that is very important
so you know they need to work on some of
these things
and
that that brings up and you know
just a comment um that a lot of people
who work in technology
um may be a little bit introverted and
not as comfortable talking with with new
people or strangers and that type of
thing and that's that's something that
people people need to practice that
skill interview yeah I you know 110
agree with you because I can related to
myself I took a career break recently
when I come back to India and had my
second you know son recently last year
so I took a career break of around one
one and a half year
so when I started applying for the
companies I you know um quickly I
started getting the calls as well so
when I giving my you know first few
interviews right I I used to get nervous
you know how I'll get the interview
because when you think about interview
right when you are sitting alone when
you think about interview it's it's
completely normal but but you actually
you know log into that
you know WebEx are the meeting and when
you see the interviewer you get stressed
out you actually get panic so the other
thing is be calm don't lose your
composure nothing is going to happen we
are here to help you out we actually
want to hire you right and we would like
to know you know how you are as a person
you know as a candidate so there is
nothing to worry about because nobody
knows
you know everything
and you know people I have seen people
get stressed out if they don't know the
answer of first or second question you
know from there that interview goes like
you know downwards because they get
stretched out they got panic and you
know I mean and they think okay now
nothing is going to happen
don't think about it you know be
confident even if you don't know
something leave it like that just tell
them you don't know because even I don't
know everything
you know there's no one who knows
everything we as we still are learning
data science is a evolving field right
every there is there is something on the
other to Lord I read books I keep
upskill myself you know just so that I
whenever I talk to you know a new data
science candidate or maybe you know a
data science audience or maybe in the
leadership I I have something to talk
about something new to talk about
so
focus on those things keep upskilling
yourself give time to you know learn and
it's not a process that you can do it
overnight or in a day or two it takes
time it's it's a you know long process
start take baby steps learn you know
something new every day spend one or two
hours you know read something try to
gain knowledge and you will reach them
and it's more about the confidence once
you know you know once you know that you
know stuff you will get that confidence
and then you release all the interviews
yeah
I was going to say I think one of the
things that you said that is a really
really really valuable thing for people
to remember is that in an interview the
people interviewing you want to hire you
because they need to fill a position so
they're they're hoping that you will be
the right person and that'll make their
you know job easier because they now
have somebody they can say this is a
great person let's hire them
um so you should always go in with the
with the idea that
uh this is not uh why should I hire you
um we don't really need anybody you're
trying to get us to force you into a
position that doesn't exist this is a
situation where you please we have a job
opening we need somebody who's good to
build this job explain to us why you're
good at this kind of work and why you'll
fit in here so that's a that's a great
change in the thinking of a job
applicant from
I have to make I have to sell myself
because they're not really interested to
I have to show them why I help them fill
this this requirement
that's very valuable
um so we're at a point where I think it
would be good if we started taking
questions because we've got dozens of
them coming in
um
uh from different sources so let me um
pull up some of these that have come in
so far
uh
so you had set a gosh has a question
about you know what are the
qualities and programming languages you
expect from the pressures are there any
things that
um you expect you see as basic minimums
that pressures have to have studied or
bring with them to the interview
to the application
the first and foremost uh
programming language you know that we
need to have is SQL
don't be surprised but SQL is something
that has been used I think 10 years back
and we are still using it and uh
sometimes we use it you know in place of
python as well
so you know that is that is the main one
do not forget about you know SQL
second if you have you know anything
between Python or r that is also fine
okay
I I I'm going to shock you um I was at
uh studying computer science at
University of California Berkeley uh in
the late 1970s and that was when
um the researchers there were developing
sequels as a database management
technique so it goes way back
absolutely and we are still using it you
know day in and days
I mean python is you still I mean we
still use Python it's not that we don't
use python or RR right but if you talk
if you if you ask me what language I
prefer or what I use you know maximum
number of times I would say SQL hehe
um
yeah
Amrita asks if you could talk a little
bit more about how your career has
progressed
after coming back from the break
has that made an impact on you know did
the break have an impact on you or is it
everything
basically as it was before
to me I think I was lucky enough that it
doesn't impact you know my does my break
doesn't impact me because I actually you
know picked up where I left in the UK so
I got you know similar designations or
you know everything in that for that
matter right
I took a break you know it was uh
completely uh my uh my decision to take
it because uh as I mentioned that I was
coming back from UK and then I was
having a baby as well
so I took the break and uh I took up my
own sweet time to prepare for the
interviews right I took around six to
eight months to upskill myself to learn
you know what is there in the market
currently and you know how should I
approach some of the problems that we
are you know dealing with
uh I I start applying to all the
companies to be honest where I think I
I'm a good where I think the role
matches my interest and you know the
designation matches with my previous one
as well and to my amaze trust me on this
that you know I got
I think I got called from almost 80 of
the companies and wow uh yeah I gave the
interviews I initially I I screwed it up
it happens it happens with everyone
I screwed it up because I was nervous I
was you know I get stressed out you know
whenever I see the interviewer so I
couldn't give my best shot but with time
it took me like a month or so to gain
that confidence no I can do it what's
there to lose right there's nothing to
lose you know
I'm still here with without job over job
I'll still be there if not this company
some other company right so there's
nothing for me to lose so I start
gaining that confidence I start
refreshing my Concepts I start learning
you know the things and then slowly I
you know when I when I was getting the
call I was giving the interviews
probably I got a call from most of the
companies and then I chose PayPal and
out of all the companies you know know
where I actually have to compromise on
the designation or remuneration so I I
see this as a drastic change
um in the you know in the thought
process in the companies
at least
yeah
amateur ask a question
um
if you're making a career shift into
data science
um
does it make sense to try to specialize
in in some Niche like NLP or or you know
applications and e-commerce or that type
of thing or is it better to have the
general skills
um kind of a well-rounded repertoire and
then you know specialize once you're in
a position
if you ask me I would say that if you
are actually making a move from a you
know if you are new to a data science
field having a
um you know the general qualities or the
general technical skills
actually open most of the doors of the
company rather than having this
visualization in one skill because if
you talk about NLP or the computer
vision they need experience
right you need industrial experience to
get into that profile
I mean at least most of the companies
are look for the experienced person
but if you are actually new in the field
it it's actually makes sense because
then there are a lot of options for you
to apply
um
now delete uh uh is a different kind of
pressure in that uh he's completed a PhD
in computer science in the machine
learning domain as a a year of
experience as a research associate the
university
um so
in
presenting that level of qualification
experience
um are there any special things that you
would advise
he's looking for work in the corporate
sector
I think there is nothing special that I
can advise because
right that right now it's kind of uh
people are looking for so
if you are you know if you are expert in
you know computer science domain already
computer science or computer vision I'm
not sure but if you are expert in that
area already then I think you might have
already covered some of the basic skills
or the general skills that is required
for the data science domain right so I
don't think you need anything special I
think you should start applying probably
um you know they for the data scientist
positions because
you are a PhD you have much more if not
I mean you have research experience
already you don't have the industry
experience you don't have the corporate
experience but you do have the research
experience
um presumably you'd be asking the same
kinds of questions in terms of you know
how have you applied your your knowledge
and what kind of projects have you done
and the
yes absolutely because in the PHD as
well they are trying to solve I mean
there is a project that he would be
working on he or she would be working on
right and uh they have applied their
knowledge they have done research they
have put you know so much of hard work
of like three to four years into that
uh so I don't see any issues with that
even if it's one project I think you
know we should go for it
um so I'm going to ask a question about
uh it experience other than in data
science directly so if somebody's got it
experience or coding experience
um how much does that translate to data
science and and are they
viable candidates for you or or do you
recommend that they need to add the
particular statistical and other skills
I mean if you ask me I would actually
prefer a person with you know
programming plus statistical uh
experience the only reason would be
because I don't have to you know teach
them how to interpret the results right
and that's the you know most of the time
that we spend is on that you can you
know analyze the data but if you don't
interpret it if you can't interpret that
then you know it's of no use right so
even though you have a good idea
experience which is kind of a positive
thing for you because you do not have to
invest that time again right to learn
that all you need to invest your time in
learning some of the statistical you
know uh knowledge how to approach a
problem and maybe pick a data set from
the open source or the kaggle or you
know somewhere and start you know
looking at that try to you know find you
know other people on the Kagan you know
how they are solving this
this problem and try to understand what
are the things they are doing
differently and and you will get to know
you know uh people from different uh
domain or people from different uh
insights
um I mean it hasn't uh has the idea
uh the impression now that we're in a
period of layoffs there's
a lot of applications for every single
job that's out there and he's interested
in knowing how to stand out as a fresher
the for so the first part of the
question is is it really the case now
where there's just way more applicants
than there are jobs
I mean as far as PayPal is concerned
that's not the case
uh we are not laying off anybody uh in
India instead we are hiring a lot of
people a lot of people uh we have a
Target uh for this yearn to hire you
know
a lot of people so that's not the case
and even if you know in other companies
there are you know there are layoffs and
there are a lot of applications
you can't help it right I mean there's
nothing that you can do about it all you
can do it as I mentioned before
you know customize your resume as per
the requirement what is the role that
you are applying for try to understand
that and then you know cater or
customizer resume based on that do not
send out the same resume for a you know
10 different profiles or 10 different
companies just try to customize it so
that you know you try to use the
keywords because maybe the languages you
know means the same but the when the uh
the filtering is happening Maybe by a
bot or something yeah I bought the
resume might not filter so try to use
the keywords
that will help another thing I can
recommend you is if you are trying to
find do start networking
on LinkedIn
try to show your presence right maybe
post some articles write some articles
it actually help you to gain knowledge
as well as you know it will actually
show your presence in your group right
try to you know have your uh maybe you
know try to uh network with the with the
HRS or with the people where you
actually want to apply in those
companies right try to interact because
then you can actually send out your
resume to them and they can you know
share it with the uh with the HR
directly right so these are some of the
things that that can actually help you
in getting a call
that's you had mentioned early in the in
the in the hour um that you look at
LinkedIn and when you're looking at
candidates are you looking at LinkedIn
to find new candidates when you have an
opening or are you looking at the
LinkedIn of a candidate whose resume is
in front of you
and then I'll look into it but I do
actually look at the LinkedIn when I do
have a requirement in the team
so you're actually going out and looking
for potential hires through that channel
so that's a
and that
by the way that means for the people in
the audience that if you have a presence
there if as finished as said as you've
networked there and you have something
of a network and a reputation there that
means that there are people who are
going to contact you directly and and
bypass the I you know I bought that
might look at your resume and filter it
out people who are going to look at you
and as a human being and say this is a
person's it's interesting might want to
talk to so
um
mono asked do you make a distinction in
in the company between a data scientist
and a machine learning engineer
okay
so when you talk about the data
scientists right
they are more into the uh the you know
actually uh
solving the business problem creating
the business models you know getting it
productionized and then you know monitor
it so that is the life cycle of a data
scientist that and the data science
actually profile keeps changing uh based
on the company based on the role right
it's not always about building the
models it's more about analyzing doing
the research those kind of things but
when you talk about the machine learning
engineer profile
if it's more into
uh data integration creating the data
marks you know uh doing the uh the
back-end kind of work I would say
related to that we have a couple of
questions one is
um is machine learning experience enough
alone or do you want to see people
who've taken it further into deep
learning technology techniques it's
completely dependent depends on the
requirement for me me so if at all it's
it's just for the uh
if the rule is I mean for my team we
don't work on the Deep learning right so
we don't need anybody uh who actually I
mean if they have the Deep learning
experience is good even if they don't
have that's all support right so it's
again it's completely dependent on the
role so there are companies who actually
work on the deep learnings I mean people
also work with deep learning but yeah
it's again we don't have if we have a
requirement we look into it if you don't
have you know look for that
and regime has another question about
um
are there different roles for data
science
workers who are doing research versus
people who are doing practical
applications that might get integrated
into the PayPal platform
or is it all one basic uh effort within
the company
there are differences there are
differences
so there are I mean because you know
with the top tier companies when the
company is so big the rules are well
defined right so there are people who
are doing the jobs that that you
mentioned exactly right there are people
who are just doing the model validation
there are people who are doing the data
science job into the governance there
are people who are doing the data
science job sale collections
so again it's it's completely dependent
on the role and the requirement
um
I think we're coming up on the hour so I
want to ask one last question I think it
relates to a couple of other people who
asked it Monica uh says I'm from a
mechanical engineering field with
um
four years of experience in production
engineering
um
how do you how would I migrate into a
data analyst role what are the things I
need to study and what should I
emphasize on my resume
I think a couple of things that you
should you know start with is start
learning SQL right start with SQL and
you can start learning python or art
whichever you know you feel comfortable
with on the side
but you can start with the uh sequel
start you know reading some books uh on
these statistics just get the you know
uh the basic knowledge you know probably
some of the uh criterias like uh what is
regression what is the hypothesis
testing uh say what is uh the p-value
these are the general things that you
know we look for the in the pressures we
look for the very basic things we don't
go you know in depth of the mathematical
Expressions that there are right so just
the basic stuff that we look for
so you know read that and probably you
know if you have time try to understand
the different
um problems that the businesses try to
solve with the help of data science
right so this will help you in
understanding you can relate it
with the with the data with the uh with
the company you are applying for
Maybe
for example
knowing some of the statistical
techniques that are used in lean Six
Sigma and production environment might
be a specific help to a person like
Monica in that in that job
is it that that might be a bridge
um so we have so many more questions
than that we can't possibly uh get to
all of them and I apologize to everyone
in the audience for
um not being able to do that
um but I do need to move on to the
conclusion for our webinar now
so I'm gonna do that
um we've gone through questions and
answers just going to mention a program
that we have for people who are freshers
because this is not for people who are
very experienced in the in the industry
but we target this at people who have
anywhere from zero to three years of
Industry experience
um but this is a program that we've
developed at simply learned with a
number of companies in India who have
told us you know we we understand that
you do
very good Training produce excellent
um graduates of your programs we can
hire as many as you can produce
within certain parameters so
we have a job guaranteed program that
I'll explain what that means in a second
but it's a comprehensive training
program it allows you to get experience
with the kinds of problems and case
studies Hands-On use of tools
including SQL including R and Python and
it's based on online live classroom
interaction so it's not
a tough study from videos what
curriculum covers is uh statistics
Essentials business analytics with Excel
but also SQL training python you have
electives and are you going to machine
learning and an elective even into deep
learning with Keras intense tensorflow
um visualization with Tableau and all
that culminates in a Capstone project of
the type of thing where if someone in an
interview asks what kind of projects
have you done you have the ability to
say I've gone through
industry-based problem
this is how I produce the solution so it
gives you a great point to show off in
your interviews
um and when I say job guarantee it this
is for Learners in India only because
our partners in the are looking for
people who have the ability to work in
their companies and our companies are
Indian
uh we provide six months of job search
support after the the end of the program
we provide
uh resume help provide interview
preparation as notice that very
important to practice your interviewing
skills and we give you access to a
premium job board so with that um
you either receive a full-time job offer
from one of our hiring partner companies
within six months of completing the
program
or you'll get your entire program fees
back so based on that thumbnail sketch I
just wanted to ask a question of the
audience before we finish is this
uh something that you might be
interested in
and we're not asking for you to sign up
today
but I am curious to know if you might be
interested in finding out more
and when you think this is something you
might want to do if you are
another 20 seconds or so
about 10 seconds
and I will share with you the poll
result
so about half of the people in our
audience today uh be interested in
finding out more
um
another third might be
I'm gonna do is put into the chat right
now
um the link to the program page and also
our email address asked us at
simplylearn.net so that you can find out
more about this program
ask us questions about it directly
with that I will
move on to thank Unity for being here
here's her LinkedIn
uh
profile link
and I will put that into the
I have that available here
not
all right that's uh linkedin.com if you
need to uh
just minutes lucky
so thank you so much renator for being
here with us and sharing with us
your your insights your knowledge really
appreciate that
thanks thanks to it and thanks for you
know uh making me part of this event
thank you so much
um we do have a
another webinar coming up next week one
week from today and this one is
um
find the link to it
um this one is also in the data science
area
but this is specifically about data
engineering and big data so this is
going to be the experiences of a person
who has a 30-year career in big data and
data science and they're going to um
share how to build a career in that
specific specialty so if you're
interested in that please join us next
week and I've just put the link into the
chat window as well or you can scan the
QR code
and
assuming you've had a chance to click
your button on your mobile
we'll move on to
gotta keep in touch with simply learn
uh you can follow us on our
social media channels Facebook Twitter
at simply learn and just simply learn on
LinkedIn we look forward to seeing you
at future webinars
and we would love to welcome you into
the simply learn learning community and
with that
that concludes our webinar for today so
thank you all very much for being here